[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous bienvenue sur
rt france pour la grande interview notre
invité aujourd'hui le tennisman russe
danila medvedev qui vient de remporter
son premier tournoi du grand chelem du
côté de new york l' us open bonjour dale
inman vdf merci d'accepter notre
invitation après la finale votre
adversaire novak djokovic a déclaré que
vous avez été incroyable que vous
méritiez de gagner qu'est ce que ça fait
d'entendre ça de la bouche du meilleur
joueur de tous les temps
déjà merci beaucoup pour vos
je vais essayer de bien parler français
parce que je peux être un peu nerveux
mais déjà dans ton sale de la part de
novak lui on avait déjà beaucoup de
matches quelques virages et paires
d'yeux quelqu'un vivant je gagnais est
lui toujours il était très très sympa
avec moi beaucoup de bonbons et donc je
suis vraiment on va dire désolé pour lui
que j'ai lu arrêter de faire une
histoire incroyable en même temps c'est
ça la brutalité de tennis il ya toujours
deux personnes qui jouent il n'y a qu'un
qui gagne bien sûr je voulais gagner mon
premier titre et d'entendre ça après que
j'ai gagnés il a perdu beaucoup de
choses hier à ça fait juste énormément
plaisir lui encore une fois c'est pour
ça qu'il est un grand champion
quel père il les trouve toujours des
mots sabra % à dire ça parce que vous
avez privé à novak djokovic du grand
chelem c'est-à-dire remporter les quatre
tournois majeurs en une année la
dernière fois ci relève heures qu'il a
fait en 1969 sa dette un petit peu qui
est ce que vous avez appelé en premier
après cette victoire à votre famille en
france ou en russie
ajarray reflet personne parce que mon
téléphone je veux pas le toucher pour
longtemps a tellement il y avait des
messages tellement il y avait des trucs
j'avais des obligations à faire bien sûr
que ma vraie chaque tournoi gagné
surtout en grand chelem beaucoup des
photos beaucoup de gens curieux affaire
a donc c'était bien sûr au début les
personnes qui étaient avec moi à sur ce
tournoi là à et après oui je commençais
à petit à petit
répondre à tout le monde
et je vais finir aujourd'hui je force
mais qu'est ce que vous avez appelé en
premier
c'était sur le terrain donc c'était à
mon équipe mon épouse y avait mon agent
bon préparatoire même pas les membres
entraîneur vous êtes le plus français
des russes vous êtes arrivé en france en
2014 à cannes maintenant vous habitez à
monaco qu'est ce que la france vous a
apporté et qu'est ce que la france vous
apporte encore
beaucoup déjà tout toute mon équipe
française je pense que oui il ya
beaucoup de qualité en tennis c'est sûr
il ya beaucoup de joueurs absents
presque presque le plus ou moins je
pense avec italie et et amérique si je
me trompe pas mais c'est un pays très
très fort au niveau de tennis
dans la couture tennis encore une fois
ça m'avait beaucoup donné mon entraîneur
gilles servat il est français il de
cannes il est il me rapporte toujours
des trucs nouveaux à
comprendre et du truc hein on en cherche
toujours la performance ah ouais après
je peux parler français ça c'est dans
beaucoup des pays du monde et surtout
dès que je pensais à parler français il
ya peut-être de trois années ça ça qu'on
sait être beaucoup plus facile à vivre
sur la côte d'azur
après le plus important c'est le temps à
là bas et je peux je peux jouer tout
toute l'année à l'extérieur et je peux
vraiment profiter de la vie est comme ça
bien jouer au tennis mais au delà du
tennis qu'est ce que la france vous
apporte dans la vie de tous les jours au
niveau de la culture dans l'éducation
etc
là c'est plus dur à dire parce que je
pense honnêtement pas beaucoup parce que
tellement nous les gens de tennyson on
voyage
je sais pas tran semaines dans l'année
dans les tous différents pays du monde
ça commence par australie en janvier et
ça finit si on parle des grands chelems
en amérique là par exemple je vais
passer je pense de trois mois en
amérique donc à fraîchement en prendre
toutes les cultures du monde
à quand même je suis obligé de le dire
j'y reste complètement rousse dans mon
caractère après
je pense oui que des russes commencent à
me dire que je quand je commence à voir
quelque chose france-eire moi je serai
toujours de dire non non je suis
complètement rousset mais on va voir
comment ça évolue
l'actualité mondiale et dominer souvent
par la politique la géopolitique en tant
que joueur de tennis en tant que
ressortissant russe est-ce que vous
ressentez de la pression du fait de
représenter la russie notamment avec ce
qui s'est passé ces derniers temps pour
les athlètes russes je pense notamment
aux jeux olympiques de tokyo avec la
russie qui a été exclu ba est
effectivement au tokyo il y avait on va
dire c'était un peu bizarre mais quand
fois c'est là le tennis il est un peu
différent parce que même les autres
jours de tennis des autres pays l'ont
ils n'ont pas compris sur les jeux parce
que nous on fait en effet testé fois les
30 fois par l'année dans les tous
différents pays du monde par exemple
après le final et moi et novak ont été
testés donc ça c'est new york je vais
tester un os à paris et à moscou
j'habite à monaco
quelqu'un habite à dubaï beyrouth donc
pour nous
tennis il est surcoté hans adam ne
consent pas du tout la pression
représente notre pays on est très
content quand on gagne quand même à
notre pays à hong hong et les héros et
encore une fois je comprends que dans
les autres sports surtout les
les équipes sportif et tout ça ils
peuvent rendre une pression à propos de
ça à propos des on va dire médias
étrangers à propos de politique
en tennis il ya zéro de ça et donc je
suis très tranquille avec ça donne il
vous êtes le leader le chef de file de
la nouvelle génération dorée du tennis
mondial avec les titres comme celui ci
les victoires les sponsors est ce que ça
peut améliorer l'image de la russie à
l'international tout ça j'espère
j'espère parce qu'encore une fois moi je
peux
j'ai pas le président de l'apei pour
faire quelque chose pour ça mais le
seule chose que je peux faire c'est de
vraiment juste montrer la flaque sur les
sur le plus grand tournoi du monde et
c'est ce que j'essaie de faire j'essaie
de gagner des gros tournois qu'il y a on
va dire à une de mes amies qui va dire
que son enfant il regardait ton match et
veut prendre la raquette et je veux
tunis juste à cause de ça qui sait ça
peut être là la prochaine champions a
donc une fois ci on parle de politique
voici simon vit ciment victoire peut
guère
contribué à ça mais si ça peut c c'est
très bien parce que effectivement
j'essaie de montrer la flaque d'eau le
flag le drapeau très haut évidemment à
dany medvedev vous êtes actuellement 2e
mondial il ya quatre joueurs russes qui
sont parmi les 30 meilleurs mondiaux
andrei roublev karine katchalov et
assène karasev la nouvelle génération
russe marche donc dans les pas des
légendes un rêve gagner kafelnikov ou
encore marat safin est ce que le tennis
et tout populaire grâce à vous en russie
est ce qu'il ya eu un creux de la vague
entre ces deux générations bas
définitivement au début à une main il y
avait on va dire tennis russe était un
petit peu plus bas que d'habitude et on
voulait leur remontée ce moment là je
pense qu'il a concept un peu moins
populaire sur les chaînes fédérales y
avait moi sur les chiens sportifs il y
avait beaucoup de mots - de tennis
qu'avant donc après quand on a commencé
à montrer des résultats on a gagné la tp
cap cette année c'était notre première
victoire en équipe pour la russie et
tout ça ça fait partie pourquoi tennis
est beaucoup plus populaire maintenant
c'est ça notre but et je suis très
content pour pour tous pour andré pour
karen pour cela il faut un magnifique
boulot aussi honnêtement je pense que
c'est possible d'avoir une une finale de
grand chelem rousse ça c'est pas facile
mais je suis sûr que c'est possible et
ça fait juste plaisir que tennis / plus
populaire que en vend aussi on va
essayer de
continuer c'est faire que ça soit
sport le plus populaire aussi selon l'
agence de presse reuters le circuit du
tennis mondial wta et la tp aurait perdu
80 millions de dollars en 2020 à ce que
le tennis a été menacé pendant la crise
sanitaire par le commis de 19 et surtout
le fait de jouer dans des stades vides
ça fait quoi effectivement c'était pas
facile pour tout le monde après on
savait qu'il y a tout le manque et qui
n'auraient gare sur télé ah c'est ça
aussi c'est ça aussi pourquoi on a joué
pourquoi on voulait toujours gagner si
vous regardez les résultats sont
toujours les mêmes les mêmes jours qui
gagne à propos de l'argent c'est qu'on a
view cependant admis qu elle avait
l'impact sur tous les business du monde
a donc effectivement le tennis était
touchée aussi
j'espère je pense que la sarre et viens
on va dire un peu plus à la normalité
finalement on avait loupé nous on
pouvait avoir des stades congrès de mon
plan et je pense que ça va bien aider
connu qu économiquement déjà dans tous
les faire ça commence je pense à
améliorer mais si notamment au tennis
dans le sport ça commence à avoir une
normalité
daniel vous êtes le premier vainqueur
russe à flushing meadow de qi marat
safin c'était en 2000 après ce premier
tournoi en grand chelem pour vous
l'objectif c'est quoi la place de numéro
1 mondial je suppose
déjà juste de profiter un peu parce que
dans tennis souvent à des tournois
gagnés il enchaîne avec un autre tournoi
où tu dois être prêt presque dans deux
jours pour jouer un autre match là c'est
pas le cas je peux avoir un peu d impôts
je peux vraiment profiter ses ceintures
bien de cette victoire et c'est ça le
plus important ce moment là après on va
bien sûr se poser avec l'équipe pour le
caïd hier y'a pas mort cela mavs en
australie ça on le sait mais il ya
d'autres objectifs le numéro il assez
dur a touché en somme là parce que novak
a gagné qu'un trois grands chelems était
en finale de 4e et c'est là où il ya le
plus de points à à gagner donc je pense
qu'il mérite bien de finir son année de
numéro mondiale et de rester pour
quelques temps après tu peux devenir nos
murs encore une fois si tu gagnes des
grands chelems et ce titre et c'est ça
mon but en tous les cas il ya un type
peut-être qui vous attend sera en
novembre prochain ici à paris avec le
masters de paris de paris bercy
ce sera l'occasion pour vous peut-être
passé de passer sur sur ce studio on
prend date oui merci merci beaucoup mais
on prend date en tous les cas merci
beaucoup d'années medvedev d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et félicitation
encore pour ce titre à l'us open c'est
la fin de ces rondes interview
consacré donc à daniel medvedev le
vainqueur de l'us open face à novak
djokovic à plus tard chez arte france by
[Musique]